[Applause]
[Music]
i'm so excited that you're here adam
scott
your leading man was just here we were
talking about the show i've been
watching it it's insane it is very
different and i love that and i guess
everybody else does too that's what i'm
hearing i mean it's a it's a
it's an office thriller with an odd
sense of humor okay so is it true that
you and your mom did like face painting
together
it's true yeah and i i actually when i
lived here in new york
my just starting out as an actor that's
how i paid for my groceries so i i
escaped being a starving artist by
painting kids faces um
wow that's so cool okay something else
we have in common that i'm really
excited to ask you about is rving when i
was 19 i discovered life on the road um
and but it's the most sort of
liberating
um i i think it's the ultimate form of
freedom why do you like it
well
i think any time i'm experiencing loss
or heartbreak or need to heal
i like to get on the road because it's
this meditation of watching the miles go
by and i well the other thing that i
like to do with it is i go and i find a
small tenting circus and i watch the
circus
and it's this sense of awe and
wonderment i mean i just like to feel
like i'm a kid again and sit in the
audience is it true that you also hopped
in your rv like you said if you're
having heartbreak or loss like this is a
breakup sort of cure-all for you yeah
also i saw something on your instagram i
wanted to pull up is this due to a
breakup response as well you dyed your
armpit hair blue yeah
you know it's just like a little bit of
subtle anarchy
blue armpits yeah i was i was going uh
through a breakup i mean i've created
total anarchy one boyfriend was just a
jerk and i went and spray painted his
car
all the night oh yeah what color um i
just used black and he called me the
next day and he's like did you do this
and i was like no
but guess what
i did
um i'm impressed by you that's that
takes a lot to get the
spray paint off of an automobile it was
the funnest night like blasted cypress
hill and did it in the middle of the
night and i don't know it just the whole
thing felt really good i kind of want to
like spray paint something together i
kind of want to like have two people
break up with us and see what you and i
would do we could thelma and louise in a
little bit
what do you think yeah you and me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
tell us about uh severance
um it's a really interesting show it's
very avant-garde very unique it's really
popular with people right now and is it
true that i wanted to relate to you
again that you work in a windowless room
in it because we we we don't see the
daylight here yeah ever
yeah well yeah we so the office is built
in this way to make you feel a certain
way and the audience you know it takes
you on this journey of yeah it's
windowless fluorescent lighting
uh
we were all going a little bonkers
wearing masks and shields no windows
and all of a sudden one day someone left
the outside door open we were filming in
the bronx
and a very friendly chicken walked onto
our soundstage
out of nowhere starts making itself at
home
it's like sitting on the sound booth or
feeding it strawberries
it goes outside and and someone's like
holding an umbrella
oh my god that's the chicken that's the
chicken i have six chickens i gotta say
that is a real looker
and so look it's sitting on someone's
shoulder like oh my god
i remember like holding an umbrella we
all became so endeared by this chicken
who had just arrived this random arrival
of a chicken
at our sound stage and it brought
everyone so much joy you could see you
know their smile above their masks and
it was the perfect metaphor for this
show where a lot of bizarre things
happen in severance and i think that the
art meets life of it all we all kind of
came to work like ooh what kind of weird
odd thing might happen on our ourselves
like the circus like little odd moments
or just to see like the beauty in a
moment like that to be moved
for from it you know i mean i would be
so thrilled if a chicken came through
this set
actually my best friend chicken is here
somewhere
bye
[Applause]
brett flower i'm so honored that you
have come on our show severance is
streaming now on apple tv plus with new
episodes dropping every friday
[Music]